[Musique]
là on est sur ma terrasse c'est comme un
navire
bonjour david giles aujourd'hui arrière
marc raboy vous êtes et ses listes
enseignant à sciences po et un peu avant
la crise vous avez publié un livre slow
démocratie dans lequel vous invitiez à
mieux maîtriser la mondialisation grâce
aux nations ces nations ces états
nations aujourd'hui semble être
redevenue une forme d'horizon
indépassable
on le voit bien que ce soit en allemagne
en france en italie en espagne chacun y
va de sa stratégie est ce que ces
réjouissances retour là en force des
états nations où c'est pas un peu
désespérant je sais pas si c'est
réjouissant
désespérant mais ce qui est certain
c'est que face à une crise de cette
ampleur qui touche à la santé et donc à
la vie des gens puisque là on est sur
l'essentiel la sûreté la santé la
sécurité c'est l'essentiel pour les gens
en a une réaction un peu instinctive du
social vous avez vu les solidarités qui
s'expriment localement au niveau
familial amical professionnel et vous
avez de manière plus politiquement
organisée et solidarité qui s'exprime au
niveau national c'est comme ça que
j'interprète par exemple les fermetures
de frontières un peu désordonné qui se
sont produites en europe au début de la
crise parce que l'état nation dans cette
logique qu'on connaît depuis offs
finalement c'est celui qui nous protège
qui protège la vie et lorsque l'épidémie
est là d'une certaine manière la vie est
en danger et sept au rôle de l'état
régalien de protéger la vie en quoi au
fond ces nations peuvent être une
opportunité selon vous aujourd'hui dans
cette crise je pense que lorsque la
mondialisation qui en réalité est une
sino-américaine globalisation s'est
développé à partir de la fin des années
1970 on a considéré que la priorité
c'était la libération des flux de
capitaux de marchandises et au fond on a
un peu oublié que la démocratie et la
solidarité sociale s'était construite
dans les frontières
les différents états nations et que ça
reposait sur un certain nombre de
compromis par exemple le droit du
travail par exemple la solidarité
sociale et que ces compromis au fond il
était très important pour les gens et
quand on a ouvert les vannes en quelque
sorte des circulations de capitaux de
marchandises on a pu mettre en danger
c'est contre nous et c'est aujourd'hui
ce qu'on redécouvre avec une certaine
acuité par exemple notre incapacité à
avoir une autonomie stratégique sur des
biens aussi essentiel que les principes
actifs des médicaments les respirateurs
les tests dans la critique que vous
faites de la mondialisation vous ne la
fait pas comme étant la cause de ce qui
nous arrive mais plus une forme d'
accélérateur c'est ça ça n'est au fond
ni la cause ni l'accélérateur c'est
plutôt le milieu dans lequel se déploie
cette crise c'est vrai que le virus a
été un peu l'agent de l'intérieur des
voies de la mondialisation puisqu'il
s'est propagée en quelques jours de son
épicentre qui est one au reste du monde
en empruntant en quelque sorte les voies
aériennes avec les passagers mais ça
n'est pas pour autant que la
mondialisation doit être stigmatisés
comme une cause de ce qui nous arrive en
revanche c'est effectivement une crise
dans la mondialisation on voit bien ce
confinement planétaire la moitié de
l'humanité claquemuré chez elle
aujourd'hui et donc il faut être capable
d'imaginer une autre gouvernance ou une
autre architecture de la mondialisation
qui permettent d'éviter la répétition et
la multiplication de ces crises et cet
autre gouvernance que j'appelle de mes
voeux bien sûr elle fait une plus grande
place à l'autonomie stratégie aux états
nations et à d'autres dimensions que la
seule dimension économique alors un état
stratège en état qui reprend une forme
de souveraineté stratégique sur certains
biens certains biens communs comme la
santé à quoi ressemblerait-il va déjà
voir la métaphore que j'emploie souvent
que c'est celle de lécluse c'est à dire
que il faut se représenter la
mondialisation comme un grand fleuve sur
lequel tout circule
sauf que entre les différents états
nations comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure il ya des droits du travail
différent il ya un rapport à la question
sociale qui est différent et puis la
russie et systèmes productifs qui sont
plus ou moins polluants
et l'enjeu d'une écluse c'est quoi c'est
de s'adapter en quelque sorte aux
différences social culturel
environnemental des nations par exemple
en mettant un ajustement carbone aux
frontières donc l'idée c'est pas ton de
démondialiser ou de supprimer la
mondialisation ce qui se parler des
trains un voeu pieux la mondialisation
n'est pas un phénomène anuff on n'est
pas soi dans la mondialisation soit dans
la démondialisation mais c'est plutôt de
construire une architecture dans
laquelle les compromis sociaux les
compromis démocratiques sont mieux pris
en compte et ça suppose effectivement
une action beaucoup plus résolue de la
puissance publique à commencer par
l'état vous parler par exemple de
reprendre le contrôle des biens publics
hors marché exemple est bien de manière
très concrète la santé ou
l'environnement ce sont des biens
publics qui sont hors marché et qui eux
ne connaissent pas les frontières et
vous voyez quand on a mis en place cette
mondialisation dans les années 1970 on a
dit que tout circulent les marchandises
les capitaux mais on n'a rien fait pour
les biens publics mondiaux regarder les
chèques des coptes successives regardez
l'échec du pacte mondial pour
l'environnement cade et proposer la
france et qui a été sèchement retoqué en
2017 à nairobi par la chine le brésil
les états unis donc vous voyez bien que
cette mondialisation elle va bien tant
qu'elle encourage la libre circulation
des marchandises ou le jumping mais en
revanche elle ne fait rien sur les biens
publics comme la santé ou
l'environnement donc l'enjeu en fait
c'est pas de démondialiser mais c'est
plutôt de remettre la mondialisation sur
ses pieds de la refaire marcher à
l'endroit en priorisant les biens
publics mondiaux en priorisant les
comportement coopératif mais en revanche
en redonnant aux états-nations des
marges de manoeuvre stratégique
lorsqu'il s'agit de se protéger ou même
plus largement de préserver leur
compromis fondamentaux vous croyez qu'on
peut changer à ce point
deux visions de modèle économique à la
faveur de cette crise je pense de toute
façon que le choc que nous avons connue
et que nous sommes en train de connaître
et qui va encore durer des années parce
que les conséquences économiques
sociales et politiques de cette crise
seront absolument considérable un point
d'inflexion majeure dans l'histoire
comme avait pu l'être les deux guerres
mondiales ou années 1968 et bien va
induire un certain nombre de positions
politiques totalement nouvelle par
rapport à ce qui était véritablement là
le monde d'avant qu'est ce que vous
répondez david djaïz à ceux qui vous
disent mais vont avoir besoin de la
mondialisation pour repartir on va avoir
besoin de la mondialisation du rebond de
la croissance chinoise pour que nous on
puisse aussi retrouver un début de
croissance d'abord la croissance
chinoise je vous avais vu le choc que la
chine a connu durant les deux premiers
mois de l'année 2020 ce choc a
profondément affecté toutes les
économies très dépendante de la chine
que ce soit les économies européennes où
l'économie américaine vous voyez bien
que le commerce international s'est
effondré les trois premiers mois de
l'année 2020 - 35% selon le fmi et omc
et donc ce qui va falloir apprendre à
faire c'est pas à démondialiser encore
une fois mais c'est à mieux se protéger
et surtout à resserrer à recentrer à
relocaliser nos chaînes de valeur
stratégique c'est-à-dire les actifs qui
sont essentiels regardez par exemple les
protéines végétales comme le soja ils
sont nécessaires pour les animaux
d'élevage et qui sont nécessaires pour
l'industrie agroalimentaire en général
l'europe importe 90% de ces protéines
végétales notamment en provenance du
brésil je pense aussi à la technologie
il y à de multiples sujets qui
mériteraient une réflexion stratégique
et pas simplement de considérer que tout
doit circuler dans tous les sens et que
par exemple un steak ou un avocat doit
traverser sur des porte containers les
cinq les cinq mers et océans avant
d'arriver dans l'assiette des
consommateurs pour revenir à la question
des états dans cette crise il ya eu
notamment dans l'aspect sanitaire
d'énormes problèmes de réactivité l'état
central démocratique avec une
administration l'eau et des procédures à
respecter qui n'ont pas permis de la
fluidité de la réactivité il faudra
tirer les leçons de sa aussi pour la
presse bien sûr et d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant parce que cette crise elle a
été à la fois le révélateur de
l'impérieuse nécessité d'avoir un état
presque hobbesien au sens noble soyez
qui protège l'essentiel
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
la sûreté la sécurité la santé et en
même temps on a pu constater
effectivement un certain nombre de
défaillances de lenteur et c'est pas
propre à la france ses propres un
certain nombre de pays d'europe
occidentale ou aux états unis et donc
l'enjeu qui va falloir avoir c'est
effectivement l'enjeu de la la
refondation de l'état pas simplement
comme cette entité surplombante voiliers
qui est au dessus de tous les acteurs
qui est très verticale etc mais plutôt
comme cette entité collaborative qui est
capable de passer on va dire des
alliances ou des who de travailler de
manière coopérative avec un certain
nombre d'acteurs à commencer par les
collectivités locales ils sont
absolument nécessaires mais aussi les
entreprises les associations et plus
largement la société civile mais au-delà
de ça il ya une dimension de l'état qui
est complètement à inventer c'est l'état
résignant c'est à dire l'état qui est
capable de vous adapter aux crises à
l'incertitude parce que nous entrons
dans un contexte d'incertitude il ya eu
cette crise pandémique à laquelle
personne ne s'attendait trois semaines
avant le début de la vague en europe
mais il y aura demain il ya déjà le
changement climatique avec ses effets
dévastateurs des feux de forêt
incontrôlable en australie des villes
qui connaissent la chaleur et la
sécheresse au coeur de l'europe
occidentale mais ça ça va nécessiter si
vous voulez qu'on reconstruise un état
résilient très différent de celui qui a
fait les font fonctionner durant le
xxème siècle on parle beaucoup d'un
repli ou d'un risque de repli national
on a vu surtout que les états populistes
ou les régimes ou des systèmes
politiques populistes voire autoritaire
ne s'en sont pas mieux sorti que des
démocraties libérales bonne nouvelle ils
s'en sont même plus mal sorti voyez par
exemple la communication erratique de
donald trump ou même la situation en
hongrie où viktor orban en quelque sorte
pro fit et de cette crise pour faire
passer en contrebande ce dont il rêvait
depuis toujours c'est-à-dire la
suspension pure et simple de l'état de
droit donc qu'effectivement je pense que
ça n'est pas une aubaine pour les
populistes creed parce que ils ont fait
la démonstration de leur amateurisme de
paroles parfois erratique de décisions
peu coordonnés et surtout d'une défiance
vis-à-vis de la science qui est
problématique parce que dans un moment
de crise comme ça vous avez besoin
d'éclairer plus que jamais vos décisions
sur des analyses scientifiques
rigoureuses enfin david djaïz il ya
cette comparaison incessante entre les
états dans cette crise qui va gagner et
qui va perdre la gestion de cette crise
sanitaire elle va laisser des traces
cette comparaison cette comparaison les
gens ne peuvent pas s'empêcher de la
faire parce que d'abord tous les jours
nous sommes abreuvés d'informations en
provenance du monde j'ai dit dans un
article récent nous n'avons jamais pris
autant de nouvelles du monde et c'est ce
qui fait d'ailleurs que cette crise est
ce que j'appelle une crise monde c'est à
dire une crise qui fait qu on regarde
tous les pays du monde en même temps un
peu comme pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale ont regardé ce que faisait
l'armée russe qui se passait au brésil
les alliances de franco et c est là si
vous voulez c'est pareil vous regardez
ce qui se passe dans tous les pays du
monde et il ya des comparaisons qui sont
faites qui sont à mon avis totalement
morbide et inopportune parce que ce
n'est pas une compétition et ça devrait
même être une coopération mais j'y vois
un enjeu existentiel pour la démocratie
libérale c'est la capacité à démontrer
sa résilience et son efficacité une
résilience et une efficacité supérieure
au régime autoritaire parce que vous
voyez que les régimes autoritaires ont
déjà commencé l'offensive pour montrer
que leur système de gouvernance et plus
efficace pour faire face à ces crises
donc il ya vraiment un enjeu existentiel
pour la démocratie de montrer que des
décisions éclairées par la science la
liberté de la presse la transparence sur
les données et sur les informations on
communique et aussi une relation de
confiance entre le gouvernement et le
public sont absolument non seulement
meilleur que ce qui existe dans les
régimes autoritaires mais nécessaire
pour surmonter cette crise sanitaire et
éviter qu'elles ne dégénèrent en une
gigantesque
crise sociale politique et crise de
civilisation merci david djaïz merci
beaucoup
[Musique]